good morning Hank it's Tuesday
oh I'm so sorry this is not my channel
and I'm not allowed to do that here and
I apologize oh what a terrible first
impression and it's still going
cut to a thing hello my name is grace
Helbig or I go by Daily Grace here on
YouTube because I make daily videos five
days a week I have been graced with the
wonderful honor of filling in for John
Green while he's away dealing with the
spawn that has happened through him with
him and in his wife the vlogbrothers
have been very inspirational to me they
are very smart articulate nurturing
progressive community or driven human
beings that exist too based on our
happiness and their own brains fortitude
and so it is really stressful to have to
fill in for one of them I have been
racking my brain for weeks thinking of
what should I do for this video and I
came to a conclusion I am not as smart
as them I'm gonna teach you how to trick
people into thinking that maybe you're
more intelligent or cultural or socially
sophisticated than you really are
let's do this try to use the word
derivative when describing something
you've just seen in that that art was
derivative of this other piece of art
sprinkling the fact that whenever you're
talking about reminds you of the film
Basquiat carry a copy of on the road in
your back pocket throwing a joke like
this every now and then yeah I
done waiting for godot I've got to go
though don't have your email up on your
computer when you're shooting a video
tell people you watch Bill Maher you
also love watching soccer fifa isn't
paris hilton's the dog's name carry
around a moleskin journal yeah you don't
drink coffee unless it's through a
French press yeah you carry a messenger
bag and it's leather yeah you wear
glasses and yeah ninety percent of the
time they're not clean because yeah
you're thinking about more important
things you know the name of a cheese
that is not mozzarella or cheddar on the
cheese board and/or cheese knife because
spoiler alert and regular knives don't
cut cheese
google it there are tiny specific
instruments that are for cutting cheese
cavemen would lose their tiny tiny
brains about it you know how they cut
cheese rocks you know what they didn't
have cheese you shop at Whole Foods
Ralph's that's a man's name not a
grocery store you buy your cheese from
the cheese section of Whole Foods and
when you do buy it you ask them
questions like you're in the spelling
bee can I get the country of origin can
you use this cheese in the sandwich you
have a typewriter in your house
NPR is one of your set radio stations in
your car you don't think the words Roth
IRA or just me naming a member of
Congress with a speech impediment you
have a very specific favorite episode of
The Simpsons and or a very specific
favorite character that isn't Lisa Bart
Maggie
larger Homer giving the brand-new season
of Arrested Development is way more
nostalgic than it is groundbreaking you
buy scones you own a wine decanter
because wine is apparently a living
organism and needs to breathe cuz that's
gonna make it taste entirely different
and metal and fruit you either wear a
non-digital watch or one that looks like
a tiny calculator reblog the new yorker
water mac and cheese at restaurants but
only when it has Gruyere cheese in it a
lot of this is about cheese you love wes
anderson movies it's not delicious
unless it's covered in truffle oil try
calling lines cues your children's names
don't end in a you use the words Ira
Glass and Neil deGrasse Tyson pretend
you don't know the food network cable
box number 350 I don't let by a
telescope by one book about architecture
download rosetta stone but like in
I have French and Spanish get a friend
with a Prius tell everyone you still
can't get over Alanis Morissette's
misuse of ironic lenin true know that
you follow ken jennings on twitter and
he's actually really funny you've tried
whittling owned a piece of furniture
that's made out of leather you only
drink scotch or rye whiskey you have
smoking pipes there's probably like
three museums at least that you want to
try to get to in the next month you've
been talking about getting Ethiopian
food for five years yeah you have a bike
hanging on your wall you understand
sarcasm Hank I'll see you on Friday I
labored over this but not like John's
wife hey-oh alright